WE COULDN'T BE MORE HONORED THAT
YOU ARE HERE ON THIS TRULY
SPECIAL DAY, CELEBRATING THE NEW
SENATORS AND RETURNING SENATORS.
IF WE COULD PLEASE GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE, PLEASE, AND
SAY WELCOME. TO THE HOUR OF
12:00 HAVING ARRIVED PURSUANT TO
ARTICLE FOUR, SECTION THREE, Ã
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION,
THE SENATE IS GOING TO COME TO
ORDER THE SENATORS, WE'RE GOING
TO ASK EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
AND OUR GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE SEATS. AND
PURSUANT TO SECTION 9150 OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE, ERIKA
CONTRERAS, SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE KATRINA RODRIGUEZ,
SERGEANT AT ARMS, AND MATTHEW
BURNS, MINUTE CLERK, ARE IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES TO
COMMENCE THE CONVENING OF THE
2025 2026 SESSION OF THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH A MUSICAL PRELUDE. IF WE
COULD PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME
TO THE SACRAMENTO WOMEN'S CHORUS.
THE SACRAMENTO WOMEN'S CHORUS IS
A TESTAMENT TO SUCCESS. HERE IN
THE GREAT CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE LED TODAY BY
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR RACHEL
JACKSON. THEY HAVE TWO BEAUTIFUL
SONGS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO KICK
US OFF WITH. AGAIN, ANOTHER
WELCOME TO THE SACRAMENTO
WOMEN'S CHORUS.
DIRECTOR JACKSON, WE WELCOME YOU
TO ALL THE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE ON THIS TRULY
SPECIAL DAY IN YOUR OWN TIME.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. HARK! HOW
THE BELLS, SWEET SILVER BELLS
ALL SEEM TO SAY. THROW CARES
AWAY CHRISTMAS IS HERE. BRINGING
GOOD CHEER TO YOUNG AND OLD.
MEEK AND THE BOLD. DING DONG,
DING DONG. THAT IS A SONG. DING
A LING DODD CAROLING. WANTED TO
HEAR WORDS OF A CHEER FROM
EVERYWHERE. FILLING THE AIR. OH
HOW THEY SOUND. RAISING THE
SOUND OVER HILL AND DALE.
TELLING THEM TO GAILY THEY RING.
WHILE PEOPLE SING SONGS OF GOOD
CHEER CHRISTMAS IS HERE. MERRY,
MERRY, MERRY, MERRY CHRISTMAS.
MERRY, MERRY, MERRY, MERRY
CHRISTMAS. ON THEY SEND ON
WITHOUT END. THEIR JOYFUL TONE
TO EVERY HOME. HARK, HOW THE
BELLS, SWEET SILVER BELLS ALL
SEEM TO SAY. THROW CARES AWAY.
CHRISTMAS IS HERE. BRING JOY TO
YOUNG AND OLD. WEAK AND THE BOLD.
DING DONG. DING DONG, DING DONG.
RING. ALL CAN ONE SEEM TO HEAR
WORDS OF GOOD CHEER FROM
EVERYWHERE. FILLING THE AIR. OH,
HOW THEY POUND. RAISING THE
SOUND IN THE DARK. TILL IN THE
RING. WHILE PEOPLE SING SONGS OF
GOOD CHEER CHRISTMAS IS HERE.
NHÀ. MERRY, MERRY, MERRY
CHRISTMAS. MERRY, MERRY, MERRY,
MERRY CHRISTMAS. THEY SEND ON
WITHOUT IT. THEIR JOYFUL JOY IN
EVERY HOME. DONG. TO EVERY HOME.
DING DONG DING. GÒM.
THREE. AND YOU'LL BE IN A WORLD
OF PURE IMAGINATION. LOOK INSIDE
YOU SEE INTO YOUR IMAGINATION
AND BELIEVE IN THE SPIN.
TRAVELING IN THE WORLD.
MIGRATION WHAT YOU SEE WILL BE
FINE. ESTÁN. IT WILL SOON. BE
ROUND AND YOU NEED ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO DO THIS WATCH YOU CHANGE
THE WORLD. THERE'S NOTHING TO
IT. THERE IS NO LIFE. I KNOW TO
COMPARE WITH PURE IMAGINATION.
WITH YOU THERE YOU WILL BE FREE.
YOU.
WILL. SEE? LOOK AROUND AND SEE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO. IF YOU
WANT TO CHANGE THE WORLD,
THERE'S NOTHING TO IT. THERE IS
NO LIFE. I KNOW TO COMPARE WITH
YOUR IMAGINATION. LIVING THERE.
YOU'LL BE FREE IF YOU CHOOSE.
YOU WISH. TO BE.
IF YOU. KICKING OFF THE 2025
2026 CEREMONY, CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO THE
SACRAMENTO WOMEN'S CHORUS? WHO?
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU,
BUT I STARTED GETTING MISTY
EYED, SO WE'RE GRATEFUL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE. AND TO OUR GUESTS, WE'RE
GOING TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SENATORS AND SENATORS ELECT AND
ALL GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE RISE. WE'RE
GOING TO BE LED IN PRAYER TODAY
BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK EACH OF YOU TO PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE COLORS BY
THE CAL FIRE COLOR GUARD, LOCAL
2881, SISTER MICHELLE. GOOD
MORNING. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING,
SENATOR MCGUIRE. AND LET US
REMEMBER THAT WE ARE ALWAYS IN
THE PRESENCE OF HOLY MYSTERY. IN
1954, LILLIAN SMITH POSED THE
FOLLOWING QUESTIONS IN HER BOOK,
THE JOURNEY A CENTURY FROM NOW.
WHAT SHALL BE SAID OF OUR
JOURNEY IN THESE TIMES? AND WHO
SHALL THE SHAPERS HAVE BEEN?
SHALL THEY BE THE HOPEFUL
DREAMERS WHO WERE STRONG ENOUGH
TO SUFFER FOR THE DREAM, OR THE
FEARFUL PESSIMISTS WHO WERE
CONVINCED THAT DREAMING AND HOPE
ARE FOR SLEEPERS ONLY, NOT FOR
THOSE AWAKE TO THE AGE A CENTURY
FROM NOW SHALL HOPE HAVE BEEN
STRONG ENOUGH TO ENABLE LIVING
WITH UNANSWERABLE QUESTIONS. OR
SHALL THE PAIN THAT A
TRANSITIONAL AGE NECESSARILY
BRINGS HAVE CAUSED A RETREAT TO
OLD ANSWERS THAT NO LONGER
ACKNOWLEDGE NEW QUESTIONS?
GRACIOUS GOD OF CREATIVITY AND
NEWNESS. AS WE BEGIN THIS
SESSION, OPEN OUR EYES TO THE
IMMENSITY OF OUR CALL TO BE
SHAPERS OF OUR FUTURE. LET US BE
HOPEFUL DREAMERS, DEDICATING OUR
STRENGTH TO MAKE THE DREAMS OF
OUR PEOPLE A REALITY. HELP US TO
LIVE INTO THE UNANSWERABLE
QUESTIONS WITH COURAGE AND TRUST,
ACKNOWLEDGING NEW QUESTIONS AS
POTENTIAL FOR THE DISCOVERY OF
GREATER TRUTH AND FREEDOM. MAY
WE LISTEN ATTENTIVELY AND
RESPOND GENEROUSLY TO THE NEEDS
OF ALL OUR PEOPLE, SO THAT A
CENTURY FROM NOW, ALL WILL KNOW
THAT OUR JOURNEY WAS NOT IN
VAIN. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME.
AMEN. WE'RE GOING TO RESPECT,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT EACH
OF YOU PLEASE REMAIN STANDING.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE GOLD
STANDARD OF FIREFIGHTERS HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
AND THAT INCLUDES THE CAL FIRE
COLOR GUARD LOCAL 2881 COLOR
GUARD. PLEASE PRESENT THE COLORS.
OF THE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA BY SENATOR DAVE
CORTESE. SENATOR CORTESE, PLEASE
JOIN ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE TO THE FLAG, THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. COLOR GUARD,
PLEASE RETIRE THE COLORS. COLOR
GUARD. FORWARD! MARCH!
THANK YOU. YOU ALL MAY BE SEATED.
SENATORS. SENATORS ELECT, AND
ALL GUESTS WERE GETTING TO THE
GOOD PART. THE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE WILL NOW READ THE NAMES
OF THE SENATORS ELECT. MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE PROCEED. MEGAN
DALY, FIRST DISTRICT.
CHRISTOPHER CABALDON, THIRD
DISTRICT. JERRY MCNERNEY, FIFTH
DISTRICT. JESSE ARREGUIN,
SEVENTH DISTRICT. TIMOTHY S
GRAYSON, NINTH DISTRICT. SCOTT D
WIENER, 11TH DISTRICT. JOSH
BECKER, 13TH DISTRICT. DAVID
CORTEZ, 15TH DISTRICT. JOHN
LAIRD, 17TH DISTRICT. SALAS
OCHOA, BOGH, 19TH DISTRICT.
MONIQUE LIMÓN, 21ST DISTRICT.
SUZETTE MARTINEZ VALLADARES,
23RD DISTRICT. SASHA RENEE
PEREZ, 25TH DISTRICT. HENRY I.
STERN, 27TH DISTRICT. ELOISE
GÓMEZ REYES, 29TH DISTRICT.
SABRINA CERVANTES, 31ST
DISTRICT. LINA Ã GONZALEZ, 33RD
DISTRICT. LAURA RICHARDSON, 35TH
DISTRICT. STEVEN S CHOI, 37TH
DISTRICT. AKILAH WEBER, 39TH
DISTRICT. THANK YOU, MR.
SECRETARY. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE OATH OF OFFICE
FOR THE SENATORS ELECT. SENATORS
ELECT AND RETURNING SENATORS, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
BAR OF THE SENATE TO TAKE YOUR
OATH OF OFFICE. ALL SENATORS
ELECT, PLEASE ADVANCE TO THE BAR
OF THE SENATE TO TAKE YOUR OATH
OF OFFICE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL SPECIAL GUESTS
WHO ARE WITH US TODAY. ONE OF
THE BUSIEST IS THE 40TH GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHO
IS GOING TO BE ATTENDING THE
PROCEEDING IN THE ASSEMBLY AS
WELL TODAY? CAN WE PLEASE GIVE A
WARM SENATE WELCOME TO THE ONE
THE ONLY GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, THE FOLLOWING SENATORS
HAVE BEEN SELECTED TO BE AN
ESCORT COMMITTEE FOR THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT, WITH SENATORS
UMBERG ALLEN CABALLERO, DURAZO
RICHARDSON, AND NILO PROCEED TO
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER, PROCEED
TO THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN
ORDER TO ESCORT THE HONORABLE
PATRICIA GUERRERO, CHIEF JUSTICE
OF THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT,
WHO ADMINISTER THE OATH OF
OFFICE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT, CHIEF JUSTICE
GUERRERO.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE WILL BE
ADVANCING THE OATH OF OFFICE FOR
SENATOR GABALDON'S DESK. MADAM
CHIEF JUSTICE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OFFICE OF MEMBER OF THE
SENATE. PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT
HAND AND REPEAT AFTER ME. I
STATE YOUR NAME. I, RICHARD. DO
SOLEMNLY SWEAR. DO SOLEMNLY
SWEAR THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND. THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES. THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES, AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. AGAINST ALL ENEMIES,
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC. THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE. THAT I WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES, TO THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION, WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION OR PURPOSE OF EVASION.
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE, AND THAT I
WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I'M ABOUT TO ENTER THE DUTIES
UPON WHICH I AM ABOUT TO ENTER.
CONGRATULATIONS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. LOUD AND PROUD. CAN
WE PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO THE NEWLY ELECTED
SENATORS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE? EVERYBODY UP ON YOUR
FEET AND LET ME HEAR YOU. YEAH!
WOO WOO WOO WOO WOO WOO!
CONGRATULATIONS. CONGRATULATIONS.
PHOTO TIME. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR THE
INDULGENCE OF EACH OF YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A GROUP PHOTO HERE
OF ALL THE NEWLY ELECTED AND
SWORN IN SENATORS. SENATOR STERN
HAS HIS BOOT. THERE'S A LOT OF
COOLNESS WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, HOLD ON,
HOLD ON. AND THE BOO IS BACK. I
GOT IT, I GOT. OH THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO MISS A
PHOTO. FUTURE SENATOR, YOU'RE
TIED YOUR TIE. SORRY. THE BABY,
THE. ROOM SERVICE. CAN WE GIVE
ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO THE
NEWLY SWORN IN SENATORS HERE IN
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
WELL DONE. YOU KNOW, THIS IS
TRULY AN EMOTIONAL DAY. MANY OF
THE SENATORS WHO ARE RETURNING
NEVER HAD A FORMAL SWEARING IN
CEREMONY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
HERE TODAY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TO ALL OF OUR
GUESTS, IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING
ALONG IN YOUR PROGRAM TODAY, THE
NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS SENATE
RESOLUTION WON BY MAJORITY
LEADER GONZALEZ. MR. SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION? SENATE RESOLUTION
ONE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE
TO HOLDOVER SENATORS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, SENATE RESOLUTION ONE
WOULD HAVE THE HOLDOVER SENATORS
TAKE THEIR SEATS AND HAVE THIS
HOUSE PROCEED TO ORGANIZE. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SENATOR GONZALEZ. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION? SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE. GONZALEZ
IS REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THIS VIA VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION, PLEASE STATE. AYE.
ALL OPPOSED? THE AYES HAVE IT,
AND THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MAKE IT OFFICIAL. THE SECRETARY
IS GOING TO CALL THE ROLL OF ALL
SENATORS OF THE NEWLY
CONSTITUTED CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. MR. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GIL ARCHULETA, ARAGON. ASHBY.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. CABALDON.
CABALLERO. CERVANTES. CHOI.
CORTEZ. DALY. DURAZO. GONZALEZ.
GRAYSON. GROVE. HURTADO. JONES.
LAIRD. LIMON. MCGUIRE. MCNERNEY.
MENGIBAR. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PEREZ. REYES. RICHARDSON. RUBIO.
SEYARTO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. VALLADARES. WAHAB.
WEBER. WIENER. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, I THINK THAT DESERVES
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. THE NEWLY
CONSTITUTED CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE IS OFFICIAL. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
RESOLUTION. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS SENATE RESOLUTION
NUMBER TWO BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER, SENATOR GONZALEZ. MR.
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THE SENATE RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ, RELATIVE TO
THE ELECTION OF OFFICERS?
SENATOR GONZALEZ, GOOD
AFTERNOON. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, SENATE RESOLUTION TWO
WILL ELECT SENATE SENATOR MIKE
MCGUIRE AS PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE
OF THE SENATE. ERIKA CONTRERAS
AS SECRETARY OF THE SENATE, AND
KATRINA RODRIGUEZ AS SERGEANT AT
ARMS OF THE SENATE. AS OUR
OFFICERS OF THE SENATE FOR THE
2526 REGULAR SESSION. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, SECRETARY CONTRERAS
WORKS TIRELESSLY ON BEHALF OF
THE SENATE AND MANAGES THIS BODY
AND OUR STAFF WITH GRACE,
FAIRNESS AND INTEGRITY. SHE
HAILS FROM AGUAS CALIENTES,
MEXICO, JUST LIKE MY FAMILY AND
SHE WORKS SO HARD ON BEHALF OF
OUR SENATE. SHE IS THE GLUE THAT
HOLDS US TOGETHER. KATRINA
RODRIGUEZ WORKS DILIGENTLY TO
KEEP US, OUR STAFF AND THE
PUBLIC SAFE DAY IN AND DAY OUT,
AND HER PROFESSIONALISM AND KIND
DEMEANOR ARE UNMATCHED. AND WE
THANK FOR SO MUCH FOR HER WORK.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST, OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE, MIKE
MCGUIRE. A FORCE TO BE RECKONED
WITH A SON OF SONOMA, THE
ENERGIZER BUNNY. AND OF COURSE,
AN INCREDIBLE FRIEND TO MANY OF
US. REGARDLESS OF PARTY
AFFILIATION, HE HAS WORKED AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO OVERSEE
OUR IMPORTANT WORK IN THIS
CHAMBER AND WILL HELP LEAD OUR
STATE TO STRENGTHEN US AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THESE YEARS
AHEAD. WE THANK HIM FOR HIS
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA. AND WITH
THAT, I URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'M GOING TO START
GETTING EMOTIONAL NOW, MADAM
MAJORITY LEADER. I'M NERVOUS. IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS RESOLUTION? SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS REQUESTING AN AYE
VOTE. THIS WILL BE A VOICE VOTE
OF THE BODY. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
OF THE RESOLUTION, PLEASE STATE
AYE. ALL OPPOSED? HOT DANG.
THERE WE GO. THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. THE AYES HAVE IT.
MEMBERS OF THE STATE SENATE. THE
OATH OF OFFICE WILL NOW BE
ADMINISTERED TO THE NEWLY
ELECTED OFFICERS OF THE SENATE
BY THE HONORABLE PATRICIA
GUERRERO, CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GOING TO REQUEST THAT
SECRETARY CONTRERAS AND CHIEF
SERGEANT RODRIGUEZ TO PLEASE
COME TO THE BAR OF THE SENATE.
I'M GOING TO REQUEST ERICA
MCGUIRE, MY WIFE, TO PLEASE
ADVANCE TO THE ROSTRUM, WHICH I
KNOW SHE'S VERY EXCITED ABOUT.
SO, ERICA, IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YEP. WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE SERGEANT AT ARMS.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. QUICK RUN
OF SHOW. WE'LL BE OFFICIALLY
SWORN IN. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE CHIEF JUSTICE SWEAR IN
THE SECRETARY. IN THE CHIEF
SERGEANT. MADAM CHIEF JUSTICE.
CONGRATULATIONS. PLEASE, FOR THE
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE
OF THE SENATE, PLEASE RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND AND REPEAT AFTER ME.
I STATE YOUR NAME. I, MIKE
MCGUIRE. DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR. DO
SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND. THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC, AGAINST ALL ENEMIES,
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC. THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE, THAT I WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. Dð THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY,
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION, WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION OR PURPOSE OF EVASION,
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE, AND THAT I
WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I AM ABOUT TO ENTER. THE DUTIES
UPON WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER.
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHIEF
JUSTICE. AND.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO REQUEST THAT
THE CHIEF JUSTICE HEADS TO
SENATOR BALDWIN'S DESK FOR THE
SWEARING IN OF MADAM SECRETARY
AND MADAM SERGEANT OF ARMS.
MADAM CHIEF JUSTICE, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. ERICA CONTRERAS VELEZ
AND KATRINA RODRIGUEZ FOR THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE AND CHIEF SERGEANT AT
ARMS, RESPECTIVELY. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR RIGHT HAND. DO YOU SOLEMNLY
SWEAR THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST ALL ENEMIES,
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC, THAT YOU
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT YOU TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY, WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION, AND THAT YOU WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES UPON WHICH YOU ARE ABOUT
TO ENTER. IF SO, PLEASE AFFIRM
YOUR OATH BY STATING, I DO. I
DO. CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THE SECRETARY OF THE SENATE
AND THE NEWLY SWORN IN SERGEANT
OF ARMS, KATRINA RODRIGUEZ. I
WANT TO SAY IT AGAIN, AND I
DON'T THINK I COULD SAY IT
ENOUGH. WE ARE SO INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL THAT EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU ARE HERE TODAY. TO THE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO HAVE
TRAVELED FAR AND WIDE FROM EVERY
CORNER OF THIS GREAT STATE, WE
WANT TO SAY WELCOME TO YOUR
CAPITOL, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL, AND ESPECIALLY TO THE
FAMILIES OF SENATORS. THE
FAMILIES OF SENATORS MAKE
ENORMOUS SACRIFICES TO LET THOSE
WHO SERVE IN THIS AUGUST BODY DO
THE JOB THAT THEY LOVE. BUT I
HOPE THAT YOU KNOW THE JOB. THE
JOB IS NEVER MORE IMPORTANT THAN
YOU ARE, AND NOTHING, NOTHING
CAN EVER MATCH THE LOVE WE HAVE
FOR EACH OF YOU. WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL YOU ARE HERE. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATORS? ON
BEHALF OF THIS BODY, I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY A FEW THANK
YOUS. WE NEED TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
CHIEF JUSTICE FOR ATTENDING OUR
CEREMONY AND SWEARING IN.
SENATORS. WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THANK YOU TO DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER, SECRETARY OF STATE. CAN
WE PLEASE GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND SAY THANK YOU? WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA,
COMPTROLLER MALIA COHEN, FIONA
MÀ, TREASURER, ALONG WITH BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION EQUALIZATION
CHAIR SALLY LIEBER FOR ATTENDING
TODAY. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE? WE ARE ALSO
HONORED BY THE PRESENCE OF
SEVERAL RETIRED SENATORS WHO ARE
HERE TODAY, AND WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM AND
THEN ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE RETIRED
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE,
EVEN THOUGH HE NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION, THE ONE, THE ONLY
MR. JOHN BURTON. WE ARE ALSO
TOUCHED THAT PRESIDENT PRO TEM
STEINBERG IS HERE. WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK HIM FOR HIS AMAZING
WORK AS THE MAYOR OF SACRAMENTO.
JUST RETIRED. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE
PRO TEM STEINBERG A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE? TO ALL OF THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS, MAYORS AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND TRIBAL
LEADERS WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
TO OUR FRIENDS AND LABOR AND THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TOGETHER.
TOGETHER YOU KEEP THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY HUMMING,
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOU. AND
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO CONGRATULATE ALL THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO ARE BEING
SWORN IN TODAY. YOU KNOW, THE
ASSEMBLY'S SUCCESS IS OUR
SUCCESS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR WORK TOGETHER IN THE MONTHS
TO COME. THE FACT IS, THIS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, IT IS
TRULY A SPECIAL PLACE. YOU KNOW,
IN 175 YEARS OF STATEHOOD, ONLY
1199 CALIFORNIANS HAVE SERVED AS
SENATORS. AS LEADER, JONES
STATED LAST NIGHT, EACH SENATOR
IS TRULY 1 IN 1,000,000. AND TO
ALL THOSE RETURNING SENATORS AND
SENATORS WHO ARE NEW TO THESE
CHAMBERS, I HOPE YOU JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TODAY. LOOK AROUND THESE
AMAZING SURROUNDINGS. IT IS A
SURREAL MOMENT AND YOU ALL WORK
SO INCREDIBLY HARD TO GET HERE.
SENATORS KNOCKED ON THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF DOORS, HOSTED
COUNTLESS COMMUNITY MEETINGS,
PHONE CALL AFTER PHONE CALL TO
VOTERS EATING COLD PIZZA ALMOST
EVERY NIGHT AT YOUR
HEADQUARTERS. LET'S BE CANDID.
IT TAKES COURAGE. IT TAKES
COURAGE TO PUT YOUR NAME ON THE
BALLOT AND PUT YOURSELF OUT
THERE FOR CRITICISM. BUT YOU ARE
HERE NOW BECAUSE YOU PUT IN THE
WORK YOU EARNED THE COMMUNITY'S
TRUST, AND THE VOTERS SAW YOUR
PASSION AND TODAY, TODAY, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, IT'S TIME TO GET
TO WORK. SENATORS, ARE YOU READY
TO GO? LET ME HEAR YOU. COME ON
NOW. YOU KNOW THIS THIS
AFTERNOON IS A HISTORIC DAY IN
OUR STATE'S CAPITAL. THERE ARE
MORE MEMBERS OF COLOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE THAN ANY
OTHER TIME IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. WE CONTINUE TO SEE
GAINS WITH LGBTQ MEMBERSHIP. AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER, THE
FIRST TIME EVER, THE SENATE HAS
REACHED A HISTORIC MILESTONE
WITH PARITY BETWEEN WOMEN AND
MEN IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. AND I HOPE THAT YOU ARE
WITH ME. IT IS ABOUT TIME. LET
ME HEAR YOU, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
LOOK, CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION IN, IN MANY
THINGS. AND THESE WOMEN LEADERS,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE,
THEY ARE LEADING THE WAY TO
UPLIFT THE LIVES OF MILLIONS IN
THE GOLDEN STATE. AND TODAY AND
EVERY DAY WE CELEBRATE THEM, WE
CELEBRATE THEIR HARD WORK, AND
WE CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY MAKES
CALIFORNIA STRONG AND CANDIDLY
SEPARATES THIS STATE FROM THE
REST OF THE PACK. I HOPE THAT WE
CAN ALL AGREE, ESPECIALLY IN
THIS TIME IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
LET US NEVER FORGET CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH. IT IS
WHO WE ARE AND WHO WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN, AND WE WILL FIGHT LIKE
HELL TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
EVERYONE WHO CALLS CALIFORNIA
HOME IN THE YEARS TO COME,
INCLUDING OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE THE BACKBONE
OF OUR ECONOMY AND AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE FABRIC OF OUR
SUCCESS. ARE YOU READY TO GO?
CALIFORNIA, THE GOLDEN STATE,
THE GOLDEN STATE IS WHERE THE
AMERICAN NATION MEETS THE
PACIFIC OCEAN AND THE FUTURE. WE
FEED THE COUNTRY AND SUPPLY THE
WORLD WHERE THE LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY IN AMERICA,
WE EXPORT ALMONDS. WE EXPORT THE
BEST WINE IN THE WORLD, ORANGES
AND STRAWBERRIES. AND YES, WE
EXPORT APPLE. CALIFORNIA'S
ENTREPRENEURIAL, ENTREPRENEURIAL
HISTORY IS SEEN IN THE MINES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE MOVIES
FILMED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
THE MICROCHIPS THAT ARE
DEVELOPED IN THE SILICON VALLEY,
AND THE MEDICAL MIRACLES THAT
ARE BEING ACHIEVED RIGHT NOW IN
THE GREAT COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO,
CALIFORNIA, MAY BEACH. BUT LET
ME BE CLEAR WE NEVER COAST.
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALWAYS
LEARNING. WE ARE ALWAYS LEADING.
WE ARE ALWAYS DISCOVERING. AND
YES, CALIFORNIA IS ALWAYS
LEADING. TODAY, WE HAVE A
SPECIAL RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
KEEP THE CALIFORNIA SPIRIT
THRIVING, TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
SHINE EVEN BRIGHTER, AND TO
DELIVER FOR ALL OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW, WE COME
TOGETHER TODAY. WE COME TOGETHER
TODAY, BOTH IN REGULAR AND IN
SPECIAL SESSION, TO DO THE WORK
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE ALL WORK
FOR. WE PUT CALIFORNIANS FIRST.
AND KNOWING THIS AND KNOWING
WHAT'S AHEAD, THIS SENATE MUST
DOUBLE DOWN ON OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE LIFE MORE AFFORDABLE AND
LIVABLE, MAKE OUR ECONOMY WORK
FOR ALL, AND NOT JUST A
PRIVILEGED FEW. WE NEED TO LOWER
ENERGY COSTS, BUILD MORE
HOUSING, CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
OUR KIDS IN STRONG PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, MODERNIZE OUR ELECTRIC
GRID, CREATE FAMILY SUSTAINING
GOOD UNION JOBS AND WE NEED TO
GET FOLKS OFF OUR STREETS, GET A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD AND CONNECT
THEM TO CARE. AND I WANT TO BE.
AND LET ME SAY THIS IF
WASHINGTON DC REFUSES TO TACKLE
CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE COMING
FOUR YEARS, MARK, MARK MY WORD,
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD
AS WE ALWAYS HAVE BECAUSE HERE
IN THE GOLDEN STATE, HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE, WE FIGHT TO LIFT
UP EVERY PERSON, NO MATTER YOUR
BACKGROUND, NO MATTER YOUR SKIN
COLOR, WHO WHO YOU ARE, WHO YOU
LOVE AND HOW YOU IDENTIFY. THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA WAY. AND LET'S
BE CRYSTAL CLEAR WE WILL ALWAYS
STAND STRONG FOR WOMEN AND
PROTECT SAFE AND UNFETTERED
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE AND ABORTION CARE. ARE YOU
READY TO GO, CALIFORNIA? LET ME
HEAR YOU. THIS IS THE MOMENT.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT. IT IS UP TO
EACH ONE OF US. ALL OF US,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE,
TO BE ABLE TO FEEL THE WEIGHT OF
THIS TIME AND TO BE ABLE TO STEP
UP TO MEET IT. YOU KNOW,
AMERICA'S SUN MAY SET IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT TOGETHER WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUTURE CONTINUES TO RISE HERE AS
WELL. I WANT TO CLOSE WITH THIS
ON THE LAST NIGHT OF LAST
SESSION, I TALKED ABOUT DRIVING
ALONG THE RURAL NORTH COAST
WHERE I LIVE, WHERE MY FAMILY
HAS CALLED HOME FOR FOUR
GENERATIONS. AND WHAT I SAID IS,
WHEN IT LOOKS LIKE THINGS MAY BE
GETTING DARK, YOU TURN THE
BRIGHT LIGHTS ON AND THAT'S WHAT
WE ALL NEED TO DO HERE TOGETHER.
TURN THE BRIGHT LIGHTS ON, WORK
EVEN HARDER, THINK EVEN SMARTER
AND DO EVEN BETTER. ARE WE GOING
TO FIGHT TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE,
THE POLICIES AND THE PROGRESS
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA GREAT?
ABSOLUTELY. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE MAT FOR THEM. BUT WE ALSO
CAN'T FORGET WE HAVE A LOT TO
FIX IN THIS STATE AS WELL. FIX
THE TOUGHEST CHALLENGES FACING
OUR COMMUNITIES WITH THE
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO BRING FORWARD. I'M
FIRM IN THE BELIEF THE HIGHEST
CALLING IN LIFE IS TO HELP
OTHERS TO FIGHT FOR THOSE WHO
CAN'T FIGHT FOR THEMSELVES AND
TO WORK TOGETHER NO MATTER YOUR
PARTY AFFILIATION. BECAUSE
WORKING TOGETHER IS THE ONLY
WAY. IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE
PROGRESS STICK. AND THIS IS WHAT
WE DO IN THE STATE SENATE. I
LOOK INTO THIS HISTORIC CHAMBER,
AND I SEE 40 OF THE BRIGHTEST
LIGHTS, 40 OF THE BRIGHTEST
LIGHTS EVER TO COME TOGETHER
UNDER THIS CAPITOL DOME TO OUR
NEW COLLEAGUES AGAIN,
CONGRATULATIONS TO EVERY MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
LET'S SHOW THE NATION HOW
LEADING CAN BE DONE. BE PROUD OF
WHAT YOU ACHIEVED. DREAM BIG FOR
HOW MUCH MORE WE CAN DO AND
LET'S SHINE THE LIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA. GOD BLESS THE PEOPLE
OF THE GOLDEN STATE AND HERE'S
TO A GREAT 2025. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT EACH OF YOU
ARE HERE. THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE AND TO OUR
GUESTS. IT IS NOW MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE MY FRIEND, THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER, BRIAN JONES.
GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, GUESTS OF THE SENATE.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON. CONGRATULATIONS
TO MIKE MCGUIRE. AS TO YOUR
REELECTION AS SENATE PRO TEMPORE,
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUED DIALOG
AND COOPERATION ACROSS THE
AISLE. CONGRATULATIONS TO ERIKA
CONTRERAS AND KATRINA KATRINA
RODRIGUEZ FOR THEIR REELECTION
TO THEIR LEADERSHIP POSTS. WE
KNOW THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY THE
BACKBONE OF WHAT MAKES THIS
BUILDING WORK AND KEEPS US ON
TIME, KEEPS THE TRAINS RUNNING
ON TIME, AND KEEPS US ALL
GETTING HERE ON TIME AND OUT OF
HERE ON TIME. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CONGRATULATIONS. IT'S BEEN
SAID SOMETIMES THAT SERVING IN
THE LEGISLATURE IS SIMILAR TO
BUYING A BOAT. THE BEST THE TWO
BEST DAYS ARE THE DAY YOU TAKE
THE OATH AND THE NEXT BEST DAY
IS THE LAST DAY OF SESSION. AND
SO AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SOMETIME IN SEPTEMBER OF THE
LAST DAY OF SESSION THIS YEAR, I
KNOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
MANY TIMES TOGETHER WHERE WE ARE
GOING TO BE WORKING TOGETHER AND
COOPERATING AND AGREEING ON THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO FOR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS. FOR 39
MILLION CALIFORNIANS TO FIX
CALIFORNIA. BUT THERE'S ALSO
GOING TO BE TIMES WHEN THERE'S
HEATED DEBATE. AND NOT ALWAYS
ARE THOSE DEBATES ACROSS PARTY
LINES. SOMETIMES THOSE DEBATES
ARE WITHIN PARTY LINES. AND I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER AT THE END OF THE DAY,
NO MATTER HOW EMOTIONAL, NO
MATTER HOW PASSIONATE, NO MATTER
HOW EXASPERATED WE MIGHT BECOME
IN OUR SERVICE HERE IN THE
SENATE, THAT WE LEAVE EACH DAY
KNOWING THAT THE OTHER PERSON
ALSO HAS THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA IN MIND, I'M GOING TO
PARE DOWN MY COMMENTS. I HAD
ABOUT TWO HOURS OF COMMENTS, BUT
SINCE THE PRO TEM DIDN'T TAKE
HIS WHOLE TWO HOURS, I WON'T
TAKE MY WHOLE TWO HOURS. ONE
THING I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH
ALL OF US, AND I SHARE THIS WITH
MY REPUBLICAN CONSTITUENTS AND
MY DEMOCRATIC CONSTITUENTS.
LET'S NOT GET TOO NERVOUS. LET'S
NOT GET TOO EXCITED. LET'S NOT
GET TOO UPSET ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS HAS
BEEN AN EXAMPLE TO THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY ON HOW PEOPLE CAN
WORK TOGETHER ACROSS PARTY LINES
TO GET GOOD THINGS DONE. WELL, I
BELIEVE WE ALSO SET THE EXAMPLE
FOR COURAGEOUS BUT POLITE DEBATE.
WHEN WE DISAGREE, WE BRING OUR
PASSIONS, WE BRING OUR
ARGUMENTS, WE BRING THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US IN OUR
CONSTITUENTS, TO THE TABLE. BUT
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE
JUST POLICIES. THEY'RE JUST
THINGS TO DEBATE. BUT WE ALL
REMAIN FRIENDS AND CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER. ONE OF THE
THINGS I LIKE TO TELL MY
CONSTITUENTS, WHEN THEY COME UP
TO ME AND THEY'RE VERY ANIMATED
OR UPSET OR SERIOUS ABOUT
SOMETHING THEY'VE SEEN ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION, ESPECIALLY
THE CABLE NETWORKS. AND THEY'RE,
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN SEE THEM,
THEY'RE RED IN THE FACE. THEIR
HAIR MIGHT BE ON FIRE A LITTLE
BIT, WHETHER IT'S FOX NEWS OR
MSNBC OR CNN OR ANY OF THE
OTHERS. I TELL MY CONSTITUENTS,
TAKE A BREAK, TURN THE TV OFF
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS. NOTHING'S
GOING TO THE WORLD'S NOT GOING
TO END WHILE YOU TAKE A BREAK
FROM THE NATIONAL CHAOS AND
NATIONAL SCENE. LET'S
CONCENTRATE ON CALIFORNIA. LET'S
FOCUS ON HOW GREAT IT IS TO LIVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. LET'S FOCUS,
AS THE PRO TEM SAID, ON ALL OF
THE GREAT ATTRIBUTES THE
BEACHES, THE MOUNTAINS, THE
DESERTS, AND EVERYWHERE ELSE IN
BETWEEN. ON HOW GREAT OF A STATE
CALIFORNIA IS. MANY OF US WERE
NOT BORN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF US CAME HERE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES OR OTHER STATES. MY
FAMILY MOVED HERE IN 1978. MY
DAD WAS A HOMEBUILDER IN
COLORADO. WE CAME TO SAN DIEGO
ON VACATION ON A WHIM, AND IN
THE TWO WEEKS WE WERE IN SAN
DIEGO, WE FELL IN LOVE WITH
CALIFORNIA. I WAS TEN YEARS OLD
WHEN THAT HAPPENED. WHEN WE
MOVED HOME, I DIDN'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING THAT WAS
HAPPENING. MY DAD SOLD HIS
BUSINESS, SOLD THE HOUSES THAT
WE LIVED IN, THE HOUSES THAT HE
WAS BUILDING, SOLD HIS TRUCK,
1968 CHEVY TRUCK WITH A CORVETTE
ENGINE. SOLD THAT PACKED UP THE
KIDS AND THE DOG, AND WE MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA. AND CALIFORNIA IS
THE GOLDEN STATE. CALIFORNIA WAS
THE STATE OF OPPORTUNITY. THEN
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE STATE OF
OPPORTUNITY. YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT AS THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER THAT WE ARE GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER ACROSS THE AISLE AND
COOPERATION ON THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN AGREE ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL MOVING THE BALL
FORWARD AND THAT WE'RE DOING THE
VERY, VERY, VERY BEST JOB THAT
WE CAN FOR ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND CONTINUE TO
WORK ON FIXING CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. PETER JONES,
THANK YOU FOR THOSE ELOQUENT
WORDS AND GRATEFUL TO WORK WITH
YOU IN YOUR CAUCUS. EACH AND
EVERY DAY TO RECOGNIZE THIS
MOMENTOUS OCCASION. REACHING
PARITY HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR LIMON, ALSO VICE CHAIR
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
LEMON, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ON THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT FOR THE SENATE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TODAY,
WOMEN ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN 50%
OF OUR SENATORS, MARKING THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THAT THIS
GREAT STATE HAS REACHED GENDER
PARITY IN EITHER HOUSE OF OUR
LEGISLATURE. THE WOMEN IN THIS
CAUCUS REPRESENT ALL PARTS OF
THE STATE CENTRAL VALLEY,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, INLAND EMPIRE,
CENTRAL COAST, AND THE NORTH
COAST. WE LEAD POLICY
CONVERSATION IN ALL AREAS,
INCLUDING AGRICULTURE, LABOR,
BUSINESS, PROFESSION, FINANCE,
PUBLIC SAFETY, HEALTH AND SO
MUCH MORE. WE ARE DAUGHTERS.
WE'RE MOTHERS. WE'RE LABOR
LEADERS. WE'RE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. WE ARE CALIFORNIA. THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WAS
FOUNDED IN 1985, AND WE HAVE
COME A LONG WAY SINCE ITS
FOUNDING, BUT HAVE COME AN EVEN
LONGER WAY SINCE THE FOUNDING OF
THIS STATE IN 1850. IN THE LAST
174 YEARS, WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
MUCH AND TODAY WE MAKE HISTORY.
OUR STRENGTH IS NOT JUST IN
NUMBERS, BUT IT IS IN THE
DIVERSE REPRESENTATION THAT WE
BRING IN A BIPARTISAN WAY TO
THIS LEGISLATURE. MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS, I'D
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO PLEASE
STAND. MEMBERS. THIS IS OUR
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. THIS
IS CALIFORNIA. AND FAMILY AND
GUESTS AND COLLEAGUES. THIS IS
HISTORY. CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU. SENATOR LIMÓN GÓMEZ, AS
WE'RE MOVING ON WITH THE ORDER,
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE RESOLUTION THREE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE RESOLUTION.
SENATE RESOLUTION THREE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE. RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES. MR.
PRO TEM, YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MADAM PRESIDENT, MEMBERS, SENATE
RESOLUTION THREE IS GOING TO
ELECT SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR
JONES, SENATOR LAIRD, SENATOR
GONZALEZ, AS MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES. THIS
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP WILL LIKELY
CHANGE AND BE REVISITED IN
JANUARY. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION I'M SEEING
ONE. SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WOULD ALSO ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SENATOR
MCGUIRE REQUESTS AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR JONES IS REQUESTING AYE
VOTE AS WELL. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
OF THE RESOLUTION, PLEASE SAY
AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AYES HAVE IT. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS SENATE RESOLUTION
FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. SENATE RESOLUTION
FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ,
RELATIVE TO THE STANDING RULES
OF THE SENATE FOR THE 20 2526
REGULAR SESSION. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, SENATE RESOLUTION FOUR
CONTAINS THE STANDING RULES OF
THE SENATE. THE MAJORITY OF THE
CHANGES ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE,
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF EXEMPTING
BUDGET IMPLEMENTATION BILLS FROM
SENATE RULES 29.1 AND DECREASING
THE BILL INTRODUCTION LIMIT TO
35 BILLS PER MEMBER PER TWO YEAR
SESSION. GO US. SO I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE
SENATOR NILO. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW ME,
I'M SENATOR ROGER NILO FROM THE
SACRAMENTO REGION. AREA. I'M
VICE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET, AND I
FREQUENTLY RISE TO OBJECT TO
RULE AMENDMENTS THAT WE BELIEVE
COMPROMISE, TRANSPARENCY, AS
WELL AS CERTAIN PROCEDURES THAT
ARE TYPICALLY APPROVED BY THE
MAJORITY PARTY THAT WE FEEL ARE
UNFRIENDLY TO THE PROCESS. AND I
RISE TO OBJECT TO SR FOUR,
PARTICULARLY THE CHANGE OF RULE
29.1, WHICH NOW INCLUDES BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS IN TIMES PAST,
TRAILER BILLS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
BUDGET RELATED, BUT IN RECENT
YEARS, WE PASS ALL SORTS OF
POLICY UNRELATED TO THE BUDGET
AS PART OF BUDGET TRAILER BILLS,
AND THEY HAVE NOT RECEIVED A
COMMITTEE HEARING. AND WE
PROTEST THIS. BUT AS THE
MAJORITY PARTY'S EXPLANATION FOR
THIS VARIANCE, IT IS TO CLARIFY
THAT PRACTICE THAT LACKS
TRANSPARENCY. SO BASICALLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE CLARIFYING
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
TRANSPARENT WITH REGARD TO
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS. NOW,
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP. I, I
HAVE A MOTION TO ADJOURN. GO
AHEAD. PERMISSION TO USE THE
PROP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
HAVE HERE THE STANDING RULES OF
THE SENATE, AND I'M GOING TO
READ THEM ALL IN DETAIL. I AM
JUST KIDDING. I'M NOT I'M NOT
GOING TO READ THEM BECAUSE THE
WAY WE DO BUSINESS HERE, THE
MAJORITY POWER HAS THE ABILITY
TO WAIVE ANY RULE. AND IT DOES
HAPPEN. AND AS I SAID, I OFTEN
RISE TO OBJECT TO THAT. SO AGAIN,
WE'RE CLARIFYING THE FACT THAT
WE WILL NOT HAVE TRANSPARENCY
WITH REGARD TO BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS, PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
DEAL ONLY WITH POLICY. I URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
NHIÀU IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY, MADAM,
SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE.
YEAH. THE CHANGES TO 2910. THE
SENATE RULES ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE IN FACT, IT HAS BEEN THE
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE
SENATE TO EXEMPT BUDGET TRAILERS
FROM THE RULE 29.1. SO THIS
CHANGE WOULD JUST SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS, AND WE WOULD BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD MAKE IT MORE
TRANSPARENT. SO WITH THAT, I
URGE AND I VOTE THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. NO. ARCHULETA. AYE. ARAGON.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALDON. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CERVANTES. AYE.
CHOI. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. NO.
DURAZZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GRAYSON. AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCNERNEY. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PEREZ. AYE AYE. REYES.
RICHARDSON. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
VALLADARES. NO. WAHAB. AYE.
WEBBER. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. REYES. SENATOR
CHOI, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I WANT
TO CHANGE MY VOTE FROM I TO NO.
SENATOR CHOI'S REQUESTING A
CHANGE. HIS VOTE FROM AYE TO NO
CHOI. I DON'T KNOW. AYES 29,
NOES NINE. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
THE RESOLUTION. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE. RELATIVE TO THE
ADOPTION OF THE JOINT RULES OF
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FOR THE
20 2526 REGULAR SESSION. MR. PRO
TEM, YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE CONTAINS
THE JOINT RULES FOR THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY. THESE RULES
ARE BASICALLY THE SAME AS THE
2023 2024 JOINT RULES. THE
CHANGES ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE JOINT RULE 61,
WHICH IS LEADER JONES FAVORITE
RULE, THE DATE CHANGED TO
REFLECT THE CURRENT LEGISLATIVE
CALENDAR. BIG STUFF. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WOULD ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS SCR. PLEASE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR MCGUIRE IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR JONES
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
GABALDON. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CERVANTES. AYE. CHOI. NO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. NO. DURAZZO.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GRAYSON.
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MCNERNEY.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO. NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA. AYE. PEREZ.
AYE. REYES. RICHARDSON. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. NO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. VALLADARES.
NO. WAHAB. AYE. WEBER. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. AYES 29. NO'S NINE.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. UP
NEXT IS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER TWO BY SENATOR
UMBERG. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
THE RESOLUTION. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR UMBERG. RELATIVE TO THE
SELECTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM PLEASED AND
PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE TO CARRY
SCR TWO TO APPOINT CARA L
JENKINS AS LEDGE COUNSEL. I'M
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
BUT I'M A LITTLE SAD BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO BURST THE BUBBLE OF A
NUMBER OF NEWLY ELECTED MEMBERS
AND THOSE IN THE GALLERY IS WE
DON'T ACTUALLY WRITE LAWS. LEDGE
COUNCIL ACTUALLY WRITES THE
LAWS. WE SIMPLY GIVE THEM A
CONCEPT AND THEN THEY WRITE THE
LAW. AND AS THE HEAD OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL'S OFFICE,
CARA JENKINS, HAS DONE AN
ABSOLUTELY OUTSTANDING JOB. AS
YOU'RE QUICK TO FIND OUT, IS
THAT THEY NOT ONLY WRITE OUR
LAWS, BUT THEY ALSO GIVE US
ADVICE. THEY ALSO REVIEW OUR
LAWS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER LAWS, OR
AT LEAST THEY POINT OUT THE
INCONSISTENCIES. IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT JOB. IT IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT OFFICE.
I URGE ALL OF YOU TO BE VERY
NICE TO THEM, AND I AM PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO URGE AN AYE VOTE
TO APPOINT CARA L JENKINS AS
LEDGE COUNSEL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? I'M SEEING A MIC UP.
SENATOR ALVARADO HILL, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT.
BEING THAT WE HAVE AN OPEN
INVESTIGATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR INITIATED
BY THIS BODY AGAINST MISS
JENKINS, I ASK THAT WE WAIT
UNTIL THAT INVESTIGATION
CONCLUDES BEFORE WE MAKE THIS
APPOINTMENT. AND I ALSO ASKING
FOR A VOICE VOTE. MR. PRO TEM,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. MISS JENKINS
IS ONE OF THE MOST ETHICAL
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO HOLD
THIS OFFICE AS CHIEF COUNSEL.
SHE WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
SENATE, WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
ASSEMBLY, WORKS CLOSELY WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE,
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MR. SENATOR
UMBERG, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. I HAVE, OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS COME TO KNOW MISS JENKINS,
AS A PERSON OF INCREDIBLE
INTEGRITY, AS A PERSON WHO IS
NOT ONLY A FINE LAWYER, BUT ALSO
AN EXCELLENT LEADER AND
ADMINISTRATOR. AND I STRONGLY
URGE AND I VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. GWIN. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. CABALDON. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CERVANTES. AYE.
CHOI. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GRAYSON. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCNERNEY. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PEREZ. AYE. REYES.
RICHARDSON. AYE. AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. VALLADARES. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WEBER. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
AYES 37. NOES ONE. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. UP NEXT
IS SENATE RESOLUTION FIVE BY
SENATOR WAHAB. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. SENATE RESOLUTION
FIVE BY SENATOR WAHAB, RELATIVE
TO NOTIFYING THE GOVERNOR OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE SENATE CHAIR
WAHAB. SENATORS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. SENATE RESOLUTION
FIVE WOULD HAVE THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEMPORE OF THE SENATE
APPOINT A SPECIAL COMMITTEE TO
NOTIFY THE GOVERNOR THAT THE
SENATE IS DULY ORGANIZED FOR THE
2025 2026 REGULAR SESSION AND IS
NOW READY TO RECEIVE ANY
COMMUNICATION HE MAY HAVE TO
MAKE TO THIS HOUSE. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
SENATOR WAHAB IS REQUESTING AN
AYE VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
THE RESOLUTION, PLEASE SAY AYE.
AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED, PLEASE
SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE IT. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THE
PRESIDENT. THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE HAS APPOINTED SENATORS
WAHAB PEREZ, WIENER JONES. WEBER,
CABALDON AND ARCHULETA TO CALL
UPON THE GOVERNOR. THE NEXT
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS SENATE
RESOLUTION SIX BY SENATOR ASHBY.
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
SIX BY SENATOR ASHBY. RELATIVE
TO NOTIFYING THE ASSEMBLY OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE SENATE.
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES AND
GUESTS. SENATE RESOLUTION SIX
WILL ALLOW THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE OF THE SENATE TO APPOINT
A SPECIAL COMMITTEE TO NOTIFY
THE ASSEMBLY THAT THE SENATE IS
DULY ORGANIZED FOR THE 2526
REGULAR SESSION AND IS READY TO
PROCEED WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. I DON'T SEE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
SENATOR ASHBY IS REQUESTING AN
AYE VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR,
PLEASE SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED, PLEASE SAY NO. THE AYES
HAVE IT. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE HAS APPOINTED SENATORS.
ASHBY. DALI. RUBIO. GRAYSON.
CERVANTES, CERVANTES, AND
PADILLA TO CALL ON THE ASSEMBLY.
AT THIS TIME, THE REGULAR
SESSION WILL STAND IN RECESS AND
THE FIRST EXTRAORDINARY SESSION
WILL BE CONVENED. PURSUANT TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROCLAMATION OF THE GOVERNOR OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM, THE 20 2526
FIRST EXTRAORDINARY SESSION WILL
COME TO ORDER PURSUANT TO
SECTION 90 150 OF THE GOVERNMENT
CODE. ERIKA CONTRERAS, SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE, AND KATRINA
RODRIGUEZ, SERGEANT AT ARMS. AND
MATTHEW BURNS, MINUTE CLERK, ARE
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES. THE
PRAYER AND PLEDGE WILL BE DEEMED
COMPLETE. THE SECRETARY WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO
GILL. ARCHULETA. ARAGON. ASHBY.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. CABALDON.
CABALLERO. CERVANTES. CHOI.
CORTEZ. DALI. DURAZO. GONZALEZ.
GRAYSON. GROVE. HURTADO. JONES.
LAIRD. LIMON. MCGUIRE. MCNERNEY.
MENGIBAR. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PEREZ. REYES. RICHARDSON. RUBIO.
CIERTO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. VALLADARES.
WAHAB. WEBER. WIENER. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. THE SECRETARY WILL
NOW READ THE PROCLAMATION OF THE
GOVERNOR.
NOW, THEREFORE, I, GAVIN NEWSOM,
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, IN ACCORDANCE WITH
SECTION THREE B OF ARTICLE FOUR
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION,
HEREBY CONVENE THE LEGISLATURE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ASSEMBLE AN EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION IN SACRAMENTO,
CALIFORNIA, ON THE SECOND DAY OF
DECEMBER, 2024, AT A TIME TO BE
DETERMINED FOR THE FOLLOWING
PURPOSES. TO CONSIDER AND ACT
UPON LEGISLATION NECESSARY TO Ã
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND OTHER AGENCIES,
DEPARTMENTS, BOARDS, AND OFFICES
WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO
SUPPORT THE ABILITY TO
IMMEDIATELY FILE AFFIRMATIVE
LITIGATION. CHALLENGING ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE INCOMING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. DEFEND AGAINST
LITIGATION OR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS BROUGHT BY THE INCOMING
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, AND TAKE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION AUTHORIZED
UNDER STATE LAW TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF ACTIONS BY THE
INCOMING TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BE MAY CONFORMING CHANGES TO
EXISTING LAW CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRECEDING PARAGRAPH. I FURTHER
DIRECT THAT AS SOON AS HEREAFTER
POSSIBLE, THIS PROCLAMATION BE
FILED IN THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, AND THAT
WIDESPREAD PUBLICITY AND NOTICE
BE GIVEN OF THIS PROCLAMATION.
GAVIN NEWSOM, GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, SECRETARY.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU ARE NOW
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT THAT THE OFFICERS AND
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES FOR THE
2025 2026 REGULAR SESSION BE
ADOPTED FOR THE 20 2526 FIRST
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE OFFICERS IN THE
COMMITTEE ON THE RULES FOR THE
20 2526 REGULAR SESSION WILL BE
ADOPTED FOR THE 20 2526 FIRST
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION. THE OATH
OF OFFICE WILL BE DEEMED
COMPLETE FOR THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS. SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU
ARE ONCE AGAIN RECOGNIZED. THIS
IS YOUR SHOW. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I MOVE THAT THE
STANDING RULES OF THE SENATE
ACCEPT SENATE RULE 12 FOR THE 20
2526 REGULAR SESSION, BE ADOPTED
FOR THE 20 2526 FIRST
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THIS ROLL.
SENATOR O'NEILL, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED BEFORE THE ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT.
WITHOUT REPEATING ALL OF MY
PRIOR REMARKS, I WILL JUST REFER
TO THEM AND URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
IS ASKING, SENATOR GROVE, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES, WE JUST LISTENED TO
THE SENATE PRO TEM WHO WAS
ELECTED BY ALL OF US TO BE THE
SENATE PRO TEM. TALK ABOUT HOW
WE WORK ACROSS THE AISLE. THERE
WAS LEGISLATION THAT GOT PASSED
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE LAST
YEAR. THAT COULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED. IF IT WASN'T FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE.
SENATOR GROVE, WE COULD SPEAK TO
THE NATURE OF THE RESOLUTION,
PLEASE. SO WE TALKED ABOUT
WORKING TOGETHER. THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WE WOULD ALLOW A
BLANK CHECK TO GO OUT TO THE DOJ
AND OTHER AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO
SUE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE'VE SHOWN THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER AND WE CAN MAKE SENATOR
GROVE DECISIONS TO THE MOTION
ONLY. NO DEBATE ON THE SUBSTANCE
OF THE REQUEST TO THE MOTION.
ONLY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS AS I THINK THAT
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT US TO BE
FRUGAL WITH OUR BUDGET, MAKE
GOOD DECISIONS. AND I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD ABSORB THE BENEFITS
THAT WE HAVE FROM THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION. AND THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. LIKE WE COULD
SPEAK ONLY TO THE SENATOR IF YOU
COULD STICK TO THE MERITS OF THE
MOTION, PLEASE, IF YOU WILL
ALLOW ME TO GO AHEAD WITH YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE THESE RULES
WANT TO BE PUT IN PLACE FOR
SOMETHING, BUT WE DO NOT WANT TO
PUT IN PLACE RULES FOR SOMETHING
THAT SHOULDN'T EXIST. THIS
SPECIAL SESSION SHOULD NOT BE
CALLED AND IT SHOULDN'T EXIST.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBER WISH
TO BE RECOGNIZED. SEEING NO
LONGER NO OTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR GONZALEZ,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE RESPECT OUR COLLEAGUES
ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF THE
AISLE. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARAGON. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. CABALDON. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CERVANTES. AYE.
CHOI. NO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. NO.
DURAZZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GRAYSON. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MCNERNEY. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. NILO. NØ. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PEREZ. AYE. REYES.
RICHARDSON. AYE. AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO. NO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. VALLADARES. NO. WAHAB. AYE.
WEBBER. AYE. WIENER. AYE. AYES
29. NOES NINE. THE MOTION
CARRIES. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS WILL BE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE RESOLUTION.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. RELATIVE TO
THE JOINT RULES FOR THE 20 2526
FIRST EXTRAORDINARY SESSION.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
ESTABLISHES THE JOINT RULES FOR
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FOR 20
2526. FIRST EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION. THESE RULES ARE SIMILAR
TO THE JOINT RULES ADOPTED FOR
THE REGULAR SESSION, BUT
IDENTIFY NECESSARY EXEMPTIONS TO
SOME RULES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THE EXTRAORDINARY SESSION. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
RESOLUTION REQUIRES 21 VOTES TO
BE ADOPTED. THERE WE GO. SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
JONES ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARAGON. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. CABALDON. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CERVANTES. AYE.
CHOI. NO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. NO.
DURAZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GRAYSON. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCNERNEY. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PEREZ. AYE. REYES.
RICHARDSON. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SATO. NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
VALLADARES. NO. WAHAB. AYE.
WEBER. AYE. WIENER. AYE. AYES
29. NOES NINE. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. SENATOR GROVE, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? CONDITION
OF THE FILE, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. AS I WAS
SAYING EARLIER, COLLEAGUES, WE
JUST GOT A REALLY RESOUNDING
WONDERFUL SPEECH FROM OUR SENATE
PRO TEM AND OUR REPUBLICAN
LEADER ABOUT WORKING TOGETHER.
WE HAVE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. THERE
ARE GOING TO BE THINGS THAT I
REALIZE MY COLLEAGUES DON'T
LIKE, AND THERE WILL BE THINGS
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS I DO WILL,
I DO BELIEVE, WILL LIKE IF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PURSUES
EDUCATIONAL CHOICE TO LET THE
MONEY FOLLOW THE STUDENT AND LET
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BE ABLE TO PICK A
SCHOOL THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM
OR OUR ID KIDS THAT ARE
WAREHOUSED PRIMARILY IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEMS. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
GROWTH IN THE EDUCATIONAL CHOICE
THAT THEIR PARENTS CHOOSE, WE
SHOULDN'T OPPOSE THAT. WE SHOULD
WORK WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES. I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF YOU THAT DON'T AGREE WITH
THE DOMESTIC ENERGY STUFF THAT I
HAVE. KERN COUNTY, 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL, WE PRODUCE ENERGY.
WE IMPORT IT NOW FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES, ECUADOR, SAUDI ARABIA
AND OTHER COUNTRIES, EVEN
RUSSIA. SOMETIMES WHEN WE CAN
PRODUCE THAT ENERGY RIGHT HERE,
IF THERE'S A DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION AGENDA THAT COMES
FORTH, WE SHOULD PUT PEOPLE TO
WORK IN CALIFORNIA. HERE BY
USING OUR PEOPLE AND OUR OUR
PROCESS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THE OIL THAT
WE USE EVERY SINGLE DAY, 1.8
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL WE USE
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND WE'RE IMPORTING
IT FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T GIVE A RIP ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. WE DO
PRODUCE ENERGY HERE UNDER THE
STRICTEST, MOST ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
BUT WE BRING THAT OIL FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES TO GIVE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT NEED THAT OIL
TO, TO DRIVE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IF WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
CHEVRON DECISION, WHICH WAS JUST
AWARDED BY THE SUPREME COURT,
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW AGENCIES TO
BE ABLE TO JUST RANDOMLY CHARGE
OUR CONSTITUENTS, LIKE RECENTLY,
THE CARB DECISION, YOU I NONE OF
US VOTED ON THAT INCREASE FOR
$0.60 A GALLON OF GAS. WE
WOULDN'T DO THAT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN THE
NATION. BUT THESE UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATIC AGENCIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO JUST
INCREASE COST ON OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND THEY SHOULDN'T
BE BASED ON THE SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION WITH THE CHEVRON
DECISION. AND ALSO, IF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION COMES FORWARD AND
THEY ELIMINATE THAT AND THEY
STAND BY THE CHEVRON DECISION
THAT WAS MADE, WE SHOULD ALLOW
THAT TO TAKE PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS BENEFIT
FROM IT AS WELL. COLLEAGUES, I
THINK WITH THE BUDGET DEFICIT
THAT WE'RE FACING, I THINK THAT
WITH THIS 100 AND SOMETHING
BILLION DOLLAR ERROR THAT WAS IN
THE LATEST BUDGET, WE NEED TO BE
VERY STRATEGIC ON WHAT WE SPEND
OUR MONEY ON. AND GIVING A BLANK
CHECK TO THESE AGENCIES IS JUST
FILE A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
ADMINISTRATION. I THINK IF WE
WERE GOING TO DO THIS, I WOULD
ASK YOU TO DENY WHAT IS GOING ON
TODAY AND BRING FORTH SOMETHING
THAT AUTHORIZES US TO PICK AND
CHOOSE AND HAVE A DEBATE OVER
WHAT'S GOING TO BE FILED, A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
ADMINISTRATION. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
TAKE NOTE THAT WE GET ROUGHLY
ABOUT $240 BILLION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND I THINK
THAT OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
AND IN THE PAST, WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
HIGH PRONE FIRE AREAS AND
CLIMATE ISSUES AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND HIGH
SPEED RAIL FUNDING AND ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT A LOT OF US ON
THIS SIDE OF THE ROOM DON'T
AGREE WITH. BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S LIVES
BETTER. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE, WHICH WE COULD NOT
TAKE NOW. BUT THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS. AND I KNOW THERE'S NOT
A NO VOTE THERE. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I APOLOGIZE FOR
MAKING THAT ERROR IN MY
COMMENTS, BUT THAT'S THE
COMMENTS THAT I HAD ON THE
CONDITION OF THE FILE. AND I
THINK WE JUST NEED TO BE MORE
PRUDENT WITH OUR DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
RESPECTFULLY, TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BAKERSFIELD. I HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE, WHICH I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS IN TERMS
OF WHAT THIS SPECIAL SESSION,
MAKING SURE JUST IF YOU COULD
PHRASE SENATOR ON THE CONDITION
OF THE FILE, THE CONDITION OF
THE FILE, PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS
SPECIAL SESSION IS ABOUT
STICKING UP FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
FOR CALIFORNIA VALUES. IT IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THE LAW. AND I WILL
REMIND YOU, COLLEAGUES, THAT THE
LAST TIME THIS ADMINISTRATION
WAS IN POWER OF THE LAWSUIT THAT
WE WERE FORCED TO FILE AGAINST
THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE IT
VIOLATED THE LAW. CALIFORNIA
PREVAILED IN 80% OF THOSE
LAWSUITS AND SAVED OUR STATE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY. AS A
RESULT. AND SO WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE RISKS TO OUR STATE, TO
OUR PEOPLE, AND TO OUR FINANCES.
IF THIS ADMINISTRATION ILLEGALLY
SEEKS TO TAKE A WRECKING BALL TO
HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA,
IF IT ILLEGALLY TRIES TO TAKE A
WRECKING BALL TO EDUCATION
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA IF IT
ILLEGALLY DENIES US FUNDING FOR
NATURAL DISASTER RELIEF, IF IT
ILLEGALLY SEEKS TO USE THE
MILITARY. THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY ON OUR STREETS TO MASS
DEPORT MORE THAN A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO CONTRIBUTE $8.5
BILLION TO OUR ECONOMY IF IT
ILLEGALLY SEEKS TO MAKE OUR AIR
AND WATER DIRTIER IN CALIFORNIA,
AND IF IT ILLEGALLY SEEKS TO
MAKE WORKERS LESS SAFE, WE WILL
ACT. AND WE WILL PREVAIL. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS SPECIAL SESSION
IS ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR CARTER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
THIS IS ON CONDITION OF THE FILE.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. SO,
MY ISSUE WITH THIS THAT WE HAVE
PROCEEDED DOWN A PATH THAT SETS
US UP WITH A MORE ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAN WE ALREADY HAD.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF ISSUES,
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THEM WITH JUST THE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THAT WE SEND TO
CALIFORNIA, OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS
THAT GET SENT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED AS WELL. AND WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO IF WE'RE GOING TO SET
UP AN ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP
WORSE THAN WE ALREADY HAVE, THIS
IS THIS WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
IS SENDING THAT EXACT MESSAGE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT YOU
TOOTH AND NAIL FOR EVERYTHING.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
THEY'RE GOING TO FIGHT US TOOTH
AND NAIL FOR EVERYTHING. IF YOU
GO LOOK AT THE LAST ELECTION,
GUESS WHAT? WE ARE NOT THE TIP
OF THE SPEAR ANYMORE, FOLKS. WE
ARE, IN FACT, WHAT WE ARE IS AN
OUTLIER. IN FACT, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MAP IN CALIFORNIA, PEOPLE
ARE NOT FOLLOWING WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING ON ANYMORE.
THEY'VE TURNED THEY'VE TURNED IN
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION. SO WE
NEED TO WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
OUR ISSUES. THIS IS NOT GOING TO
DO IT. WHAT WE'VE DONE TODAY IS
NOT GOING TO DO IT. THE SECOND
THING IS USING EVEN MORE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAN WE'VE
ALREADY GIVEN THE DOJ TO FILE
ALL THESE LAWSUITS. THE DOJ
CURRENTLY HAS A FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT THEY HAD RECENTLY
TAKEN FROM AN ACCOUNT THAT WAS
NOT ON THE BOOKS, AND PUT IT
INTO AN ACCOUNT. IT'S A HALF $1
BILLION. IT USED TO BE A
BILLION, BUT WE TOOK SOME OF
THAT 400 MILLION OF IT AND PUT
IT INTO THE GENERAL FUND TO TRY
TO PATCH UP THE DEFICIT. ANYBODY
REMEMBER THE DEFICIT? WELL, WE
STILL HAVE ONE. THEY HAVE A HALF
$1 BILLION SITTING IN AN ACCOUNT
THAT IF THEY NEED TO USE MONEY
FOR THAT, THEY CAN TAKE IT RIGHT
OUT OF THERE AND PUT IT INTO A
DIFFERENT ACCOUNT. ALL IT TAKES
IS A LITTLE ACTION BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SO, YOU KNOW, WE DO
NOT NEED TO BE GOING DOWN THE
PATH OF SPENDING MORE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS, SUING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CREATE AN
ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP. SO WE
CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THE MANY
PROBLEMS. I KNOW WE PAINT THIS
ROSY PICTURE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS, AND WE
NEED COOPERATION TO FIX IT. THIS
IS NOT GOING TO DO IT. SO THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SERRATO. SEE
NO OTHER MICS UP. MIC IS COMING
DOWN. IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS, THE FIRST
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION WILL STAND
IN RECESS UPON CALL OF THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM, AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THE REGULAR SESSION.
TO OUR GUEST, I HOPE YOU'RE
HAVING A GOOD TIME SO FAR.
MEMBERS. WE WILL CONCLUDE OUR
EVENTS FOR THE DAY WITH THE
MUSICAL PERFORMANCE BY THE
TRANSCENDENCE THEATER COMPANY.
JOINING US TODAY IS JULIE CRAIG
AND EZEKIEL ANDREW. WELCOME TO
THE STATE SENATE. JULIE, WHEN
YOU'RE READY. TO. GO.
AND JUST PLAY FROM THE BEGINNING.
CLIMB EVERY MOUNTAIN. SEARCH
HIGH AND LOW. FOLLOW EVERY BYWAY.
EVERY PATH YOU KNOW. CLIMB EVERY
MOUNTAIN. FORD EVERY STREAM.
FOLLOW EVERY RAINBOW. TILL YOU
FIND YOUR DREAM A DREAM THAT
WILL NEED ALL THE LOVE YOU CAN
GIVE. EVERY DAY OF YOUR LIFE.
FOR AS LONG AS YOU LIVE. CLIMB
EVERY MOUNTAIN, FORD EVERY
STREAM. FOLLOW EVERY RAINBOW
TILL YOU FIND YOUR DREAM A DREAM
THAT WILL NEED ALL THE LOVE YOU
CAN GIVE EVERY DAY OF YOUR LIFE.
FOR AS LONG AS YOU LIVE. CLIMB
EVERY MOUNTAIN, FORD EVERY
STREAM. FOLLOW EVERY RAINBOW
TILL YOU FIND YOUR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
JULIE.
WHEN I AM DOWN AND. OH, MY SOUL,
SO WEARY. WHEN DARKNESS COMES.
AND MY HEART BURDENED BE. THEN I
AM STILL AND WAIT HERE IN THE
SILENCE. UNTIL YOU COME AND SIT
AWHILE WITH ME. YOU RAISE ME UP
SO I CAN STAND ON MOUNTAINS. YOU
RAISE ME UP TO WALK ON STORMY
SEAS. I AM STRONG WHEN I AM ON
YOUR SHOULDERS. YOU RAISE ME UP
TO MORE THAN I CAN BE. TO DREAM
THE IMPOSSIBLE DREAM. TO FIGHT
THE UNBEATABLE FOE. TO BEAR WITH
UNBEARABLE SORROW. TO RUN WHERE
THE BRAVE DARE NOT GO. TO RIGHT
THE UNRIGHTABLE WRONG. TO LOVE
PURE AND CHASTE. FROM AFAR TO
TRY WHEN YOUR ARMS ARE TOO
WEARY. TO REACH THE UNREACHABLE
STAR. THIS IS MY QUEST TO FOLLOW
THAT STAR. NO MATTER HOW
HOPELESS, NO MATTER HOW FAR TO
FIGHT FOR THE RIGHT WITHOUT
QUESTION OR PAUSE. TO BE WILLING
TO MARCH INTO HELL FOR A
HEAVENLY CAUSE. AND I KNOW IF
I'LL ONLY BE TRUE TO THIS
GLORIOUS QUEST. THAT MY HEART
WILL LIE PEACEFUL AND CALM WHEN
I'M LAID TO MY REST. AND THE
WORLD WILL BE BETTER FOR THIS.
THAT ONE MAN SCORNED AND COVERED
WITH SCARS, STILL STROVE WITH
HIS LAST OUNCE OF COURAGE TO
REACH THE UNREACHABLE STAR. YOU
RAISE ME UP SO I CAN STAND ON
MOUNTAINS. YOU RAISE ME UP TO
WALK ON STORMY SEAS I AM STRONG
WHEN I AM ON YOUR SHOULDERS. YOU
RAISE ME UP TO MORE THAN I CAN
BE. YOU RAISE ME UP TO MORE THAN
I CAN. BE. IN THE IN THE WORDS
OF OUR PRO TEMP, I WAS FEELING A
BIT BLUBBERY UP HERE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH JULIE AND EZEKIEL FOR
SHARING YOUR MAGICAL VOICES WITH
US TODAY. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE
TODAY? I'M SEEING NONE. MR. PRO
TEM, THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. WE
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE
TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY WHO
GATHERED HERE TODAY ON THIS
AMAZING OCCASION. AND I WANT TO
END AS WE STARTED. TAKE THIS IN.
TODAY, TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
SURROUNDINGS. LESS THAN 1200
CALIFORNIANS IN THE LAST 175
YEARS SAT IN THE DESKS THAT WERE
ALL SITTING IN. NOW IT IS SUCH
AN HONOR. IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA, ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US HERE IN THE STATE
SENATE. TO ALL OF OUR GUESTS, WE
WISH YOU A WONDERFUL HOLIDAY
SEASON. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY. AND ONE MORE TIME, LET'S
DO THIS FOR CALIFORNIA. LET'S
GIVE IT UP TO THE NEW SENATORS
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THE GOLDEN STATE PROUD AND
CALIFORNIA FOREVER. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, JANUARY 6TH, 2025 AT 2
P.M. THE DESK WILL REMAIN OPEN
UNTIL THE HOUR OF 3:30 P.M. FOR
THE INTRODUCTION OF BILLS, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED. THE
SENATE WILL STAND IN RECESS
UNTIL MONDAY, JANUARY 6TH, 2025
AT 2 P.M. THE SENATE IS NOW IN
RECESS. AS A REMINDER, THE DESKS
WILL REMAIN OPEN FOR BILL
INTRODUCTION DURING THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER. MERRY CHRISTMAS, HAPPY
HOLIDAYS.